all right Kid Rock he's known for his
music his outspoken political views his
outspoken views on everything he's
absolutely Fearless when it comes to
woke cancel culture he calls himself
uncan Kid Rock recently announced that
he's going to be partnering with country
music Superstar Jason Aline for their
Rock The Country tour headlining seven
small town festivals huh I wonder if
that name is on purpose uh and of course
in the spring and summer of 2024 in a
release Kid Rock said the tour is for
everyone who makes this country run and
loves America nobody knows how to party
like a small town America American Kid
Rock is also hosting the rock and roll
rodeo in Texas this coming may he joins
us with more how you doing great to see
you I I hurt your wrist I didn't realize
that was a bris thing man um first let
me get to this issue you are unable you
don't give a flying rip and you're we
say it a little differ than Rip but that
is correct correct well I mean I can say
it I mean I just say it differently I
call Adam Schiff I you know you don't
give a I'm just not in bed with any
corporate entities you know where that
would put me in a position where people
could raise a stink and I decided years
ago you know I've been very blessed you
know I've worked hard and still be able
to do this at a high level in 25 years
and I I decided when I was going to get
you know vocal about all things like
it's not a time I have never been vocal
I came out with middle fingers on my
first CD you know with my mouth just
going like this uh and I really haven't
changed the times have right but I
decided when I was really going to get
vocal surely for my love of this country
and you know use my voice you know speak
on things that mean a lot to me that
there wasn't going to be any corporate
deals and I'm fine with that because you
know I've always tried to live that
there's no dollar amount on this God's
green earth that would get me to you
know not be able to be who I am but I
think people love you more because of it
I hope so all right turned out a lot of
money for it uh we I'm I'm a huge fan of
Dana why I saw you with President Trump
and Dana and and Tucker and you guys all
went to the uh MMA what was it the
garden I UFC yeah UFC all right so he
was on this show I saw and it was about
Bud Light he took here we go he took he
took on as a sponsor now I'll tell you
why I've never my whole life ever
supported a boycott I've never called
for a firing or cancellation ever I mean
even people that I can't stand like Bill
by the way I didn't either yeah okay so
the what I worried about in that case
was the guys that have the the Be
Working Class People right the guys that
work in the factory the guys that load
the trucks they're not the guys that
made that stupid you know they had no
dog in this fight at all it's actually
funny speaking of that UFC fight I'm
standing there with our favorite
President right and someone comes over
to like the CEO of anheiser bush
standing right behind you right so I go
to the podus I'm like hey that's the COO
of anheiser bush Trump's like you want
to go talk to him I'm like I do so me
and him go over we actually had a great
conversation really cuz you know if you
put this in context why why did this
start it's like you know I told him that
night I go you signal to a lot of people
like myself like-minded people put the
trans thing aside for a minute right I
was like but by sending that can to the
trans kid you kind of signaled to us you
support this lifestyle and more
importantly like men being and women
sports or in my granddaughter's locker
room most of us draw a hard line right
there nah
what what are you do you have a
granddaughter you're like two grand kid
you're like 42 years old well go ahead
it gets cold in Detroit I guess it does
so I said you signaled that to us I said
but speaking of I was like I was like
you know someone wants to be trans I was
like I didn't RI that kid I said f you
guys I said I didn't even say boycott or
cancer I said f you I said what are you
doing injecting yourself into this
conversation these polarizing social
issues I was like you know you can be
doing so much more positive stuff just
making us laugh and drink beer but I
said I said someone wants to dress up
like a girl they want to be transgender
whatever A lot of people fought and died
for them to do that go for it we can
coexist you know in public places you
might not be my first dinner invite you
know what I mean and I'm probably not
yours and if you're gay no one cares
anymore right we got gay family members
gay friends great Co gay co-workers it's
like cut it out just be gay how about
I'm not going to clap louder for you you
know what I hear you saying you believe
in Freedom yeah but if you want to
indoctrinate kids in school that's what
I tell my let me let me say this to the
trans and gate community right now be
yourself that's you're cool with me I'm
cool with you that's how most people are
but as soon as you bring our kids into
this that's where you're going to bring
hatred into it leave our freaking kids
out of it that's the bottom how about
parents instill the values in their own
kids yeah pretty I mean I want to get
back into the bud thing a little bit I
want to one specific question uh it's
great to see you uh thanks for coming
more Kid Rock as we continue we're in
beautiful Nashville Tennessee by the way
they have no state income tax here I am
an idiot for not living here hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else